the freedom convoy truckers are
continuing to stand up to justin
trudeau's vaccine mandates despite a
major crackdown on their protest the
canadian government has already invoked
the emergencies act suspending the
ordinary rule of law suppressing
peaceful protests prohibiting travel and
even freezing the bank accounts of
freedom convoy protesters and their
supporters
but even those extraordinary measures
have not worked to stop the freedom
convoy from honking for their rights and
way of life
so the canadian government has ratcheted
up the authoritarianism even further
by threatening to kill the protesters
puppies
yes
yesterday the ottawa bylaw services
announced attention animal owners at
demonstration
if you are unable to care for your
animal as a result of enforcement
actions your animal will be placed into
protective care for eight days at your
cost
after eight days if arrangements are not
made your animal will be considered
relinquished
the government will take your puppy
immediately
then it will protect your puppy for
eight days
and then it won't protect your puppy
anymore
now i am no scientist i do not have
fancy advanced degrees but i am having a
hard time understanding how following
the science and flattening the curve or
whatever requires governments to suspend
the rule of law steal dissidents money
and kill their pets
as we enter day
704
of 15 days to slow the spread after two
years of lies and incompetence every
single step of the way
i'm beginning to think that this is not
about science at all but rather about
the arbitrary consolidation and exercise
of power which will never
ever end unless we exercise what little
political power we have left and end it
ourselves i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from murf murphy
who says so when did the daily wire
tinfoil hats go on sale in the merch
shop
just trying to pair it up with my
leftist ears tumbler yes i think the
tinfoil hat is a is about to become a
badge of pride i think the tinfoil hat
because as we it used to be the case the
conspiracy theories were just crazy
ridiculous fringe views that were
completely preposterous
now of course the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth is six
to nine months living under the current
uh regime uh so i guess we're gonna have
to get them into the shop very very soon
one thing we've got for you already that
you should go pick up immediately is
ring
you all know about the ring video
doorbell you know because i've been
telling you about it for years that
amazing doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
you're in the house on the road in the
office wherever you are in the world
well did you know that ring makes an
alarm
yes ring makes a powerful alarm system
and that professional monitoring will
give you the ultimate peace of mind it's
part of a ring protect subscription and
there are no long-term commitments it's
incredible you can install it yourself
it takes two seconds to install it
seriously i mean even even i am not the
most handy guy in the world you can
really do it quite quickly it's much
less expensive than the traditional
home protection sort of services it'll
protect your home not only from the bad
guys but from freeze fire flood it's
great go check out that award-winning
ring alarm system go to ring dot com
slash knowles k-w-l-e-s to get a great
deal on a ring alarm security kit today
that is ring dot com
slash knowles you and your family can
thank me later
go check out ring today
what is it
with the libs
and torturing puppies this is a very
strange
motif that i did not expect to see in
the last year but we're seeing it you've
got fauci and those poor little beagles
you've got now the canadian government
with the truckers puppies what if this
is a rule of politics it's not a hundred
percent true but it's a good rule of
thumb if you are on the side
torturing puppies to advance your
political agenda
you're on the wrong side it's not don't
be on that side it's i don't even like
puppies i don't i'm not a pet person i'm
a people person myself but don't you
know don't torture puppies that's don't
don't say that if you don't
heal if you don't get down and obey the
arbitrary rules that we're choosing
willy-nilly we're gonna kill your pets
that's bad it's not good that's not
that's not good government
and there's no end to it there's no end
to it you know that i love
how much i hate to say i told you so
i told you from the beginning i told you
within the first two weeks within the 15
days i said this is this is just going
to keep going on and on and on and on
and there's not going to be any end to
it
so dr fauci now we are this is day 704
of 15 days to slow the spread dr fauci
was just on television he was asked so
look it's been a while man
we've done the flattening and the
slowing and the curing and the jabbing
and the masking we've kind we've done it
all we've done it all like four times
each so
when when are we what's the number
what's the the number of cases or deaths
or hospital or whatever what's the
number at which point this thing is over
and dr fauci says
our country right now at least is still
seeing about 147 000 new cases of covet
per day but what would that threshold be
in the future for you to say okay the
pandemic has passed
you know there's no magic number but
what you want is to make sure the
trajectory keeps going down
and down and down
and i think the important issue and that
relates to one of the questions you
asked before about the cdc considering
giving more precise
metrics for decision-making that
concentrating more
on what the rate of severe disease and
hospitalization is
will determine that we don't know what
that number is yet but that will be much
more of a determinant than the rate of
infection
there's no magic number there's no i
didn't ask for a magic number i asked
for a scientific number you're the
scientist you're the guy who's saying we
need to follow the science and the
science is going to dictate what happens
and the science is precise and the
science can be relied upon so give me a
scientific number buddy
i don't want a magic number
but what fauci is admitting here
is what we have said from the very
beginning
which is that you can't follow the
science first of all what is the science
capital t capital s trademark over the e
second of all the science is always
changing because when you're talking
especially about something like
epidemiology when you're talking about
public health which is an extremely
political
scientific endeavor there's not going to
be a precise number because it requires
weighing different social costs and
benefits
and it requires governing yourself and
at least formerly in this country that
involve the input of the people making
their own decisions
but he's saying look this we don't know
there's no magic number and uh we want
the number to keep going down right well
it's going to go down
here's what's going to happen forever
the number is going to go down then it's
going to go up a little bit again then
it's going to go down again then it's
going to go up and then it's going to go
down and that's how it's just going to
be indefinitely that's what happens with
the flu that's what happens with all
endemic illnesses
that's why that's why we have flu season
that's why we have seasons because it
goes down and then the season comes and
it goes up again and then we're just
going to be locked down like this
forever if we follow this schmuck
you can't
eve even given all of that he should be
able to give us a number right this is
an amazing statement he makes he says
i think the important issue relates to
the questions you asked before giving
more precise metrics for decision making
that concentrating more on what the rate
of severe disease and hospitalization is
we'll determine that we don't know what
that number is yet
but that will be much more of a
determinant why don't you know what the
number is yet
what
you you really saw this when it came to
the herd immunity vaccination rates dr
fauci kept changing the numbers that
would be required for herd immunity
first he said about 60
60 70 percent then he said ah it's more
like 70 75 percent then he said that's
more like 75 80 85 percent
that number should never change
you don't you don't need to be in it
to know what that number is you don't
need to achieve that number to know what
the number should be
you should you just should know what the
number is that you're aiming at and then
you achieve it and then you're good
but what fauci admitted on the
vaccination rates is no we just want to
nudge people we just want this to go on
forever so we're going to nudge it up
and up and up and up and up until we get
to 100 well that's what he's doing here
yeah we're going to yeah we're going to
nudge it we're going to don't worry
trust me don't i'll get back to you
don't worry we'll give you the magic
number and they're giddy about this
fauci is giddy he's having the time of
his freaking life because he's never had
more power he's never had more fame he's
never had more influence and he doesn't
want to give it up and the minute cove
is over he's going to lose all of that
well he'll get to keep his money but
he's going to lose the notoriety and
he's certainly going to lose the
political power and so he wants it to go
on forever you're seeing this in canada
too
the canadian deputy prime minister
christina freeland is positively giddy
about her ability now to shut down the
bank accounts of these truckers freeze
their assets and take them from ordinary
working-class people who just don't want
to take a
experimental drug the fouchy algae to
potentially maybe but probably not stop
the infection that doesn't pose a
particularly grave danger to most people
she's going to shut down she's going to
take all of their assets that they've
worked for and she couldn't be happier
about it
so you're confirming that accounts have
been frozen both personal and corporate
but you're not releasing the information
and the actual follow-up is
i'm just wondering whether the bank
accounts will be targeted of individuals
who donated to the give sengo and the
gofundme campaigns are they considered
designated people under the emergencies
act meaning that their credit cards
could be cut and financial services are
targeting them as well
okay so
the names of both individuals and
entities
as well as crypto wallets
have been shared
by the rcmp
with financial institutions
and accounts have been frozen
and more accounts will be frozen
[Laughter]
when she's answered this is the
follow-up to that question and you can
hear at the very beginning of that
follow-up
yo yes we have oh you know we have oh
yeah those truckers we've totally taken
their money we're sharing it with the
financial institutions
you should maybe you shouldn't have
questioned the government
maybe maybe you shouldn't have protested
she's drunk with power
fouch is drunk with power trudeau is
drunk with power the ruling class in the
bureaucracy and in the elected
government they are drunk with power but
that's not the whole story
okay a lot of
leftists right now are saying you know
you conservatives you would have a very
different view of the trucker protest if
it were blm and antifa shutting down the
streets and to them i say
you're absolutely right
if you have not yet seen daily wires
first original movie shut in you've got
to go check it out right now
i you must have been living under a rock
the movie has an audience score of 97 on
rotten tomatoes this is a riveting
redemption story uh an absolute
emotional roller coaster it's artful
it's suspenseful it is highly highly
entertaining half a million people
watched it live during the world
premiere last week even the left-leaning
san jose mercury reviewed it and gave
shut-in props they said they liked it so
make sure to become a daily wire member
go to dailywire.com
watch to watch the film
and
on this issue of
hypocrisy
what the left is saying right now is
if
you
would oppose the blm riots
forget even the riots because it's not
like the truckers are burning down
buildings and robbing stealing nike
sneakers and you know breaking into
gucci stores but if you would oppose
let's say blm shutting down a highway
blm shutting down a street
then it's hypocritical for you to
support the trucker's convoy you would
hate it if it were blm doing it but you
like it that it's the truckers doing it
that's that's true some conservatives
right now are trying to
weasel out of it and say no actually
here's the principled totally procedural
reason no you're right it's you're right
the form
of
the blm and antifa people who shut down
streets and the trucker people in canada
who shut down streets
the form is the same i'm taking out the
molotov cocktails and the robbing the
gucci stores but the form of those two
specific protests are the same but one
is good and one is bad why because of
the substance
because what blm and antifa were
shutting down the streets for
is injustice it's for bad stuff they
want bad government they want bad
policies they are based on false
premises
and what the truckers are shutting down
the streets for is good
right they don't want the government to
suspend the rule of law and force
everyone to take this experimental drug
for no really good reason the substance
is what what matters here
and we don't want to talk about that a
lot we have been stuck on the right for
20 years at least in this procedural way
you can even hear this in the way that
we talk about the supreme court the way
we talk about court cases we say we
don't want conservative judges we just
want originalist judges textualist
judges and it's a little too clever by
half folks
we talk about it this way on abortion we
say
look when when roe v wade is overturned
that's not going to outlaw abortion
we're not trying to outlaw abortion we
just want to return to the states we
just want the states to kill a bunch of
babies not the federal government well
no i don't want i don't want any states
to kill babies i act i do i care about
the substance i want to outlaw abortion
throughout the country okay and i'm
going to be honest about that and the
left knows that that's what we deep down
want to do and we know it too okay and
and i think if we're a little more
honest about the substance here then
we're going to make a lot more sense and
politically we're going to be more
effective
it's about what we are doing
that is so wrong it's
sometimes people say i'm i'm anti i'm
pro-vaccine but i'm anti-mandate
and
to me this doesn't quite make sense okay
the there is a precedent for vaccine
mandates not at the federal government
level not with osha the occupational
safety and health administration doing
it like biden's trying to use this work
around but there is some precedent
george washington did it to the
continental troops okay there's a
supreme court case from over 100 years
ago that says that at the local level
you can have a mandate for an
inoculation
but
the issue is this vaccine
this vaccine which doesn't do what we
were told that it would do
which was created using a completely new
vaccine technology for which there is no
long-term
data
and
and it's a vaccine to fight a virus that
does not pose a great threat to most
people so it's actually the details do
really matter here and people are
rebelling against that you're seeing
this in austria right now austria is
doing a complete u-turn
on what they call corona apartheid
policies austria's coalition government
just announced that the vast majority of
lockdown measures in place in the
country including all corona apartheid
restrictions that's the phrase used
among the opposition in australia
that are specifically creating a new set
of rules and laws for the unvaccinated
people they're going to be scrapped by
march 5th
right you just got to fight back you
just you have to go in and realize that
this whole follow the science thing has
always been completely fake it's always
been propaganda by our ruling political
class to keep us going like this forever
and to perpetually take more and more
and more of our rights and way of life
away in some cases our money and in some
places are freaking puppies they're
going to go take and kill don't let them
do it just stand up and say no like
they're doing in austria you're seeing
this now in the senate ted cruz my pal
ted cruz is
now filing an amendment
in the u.s senate to defund schools that
mandate that kids get the kovid vaccine
so
the amendment would modify the 1.6
trillion dollar continuing resolution
that would fund the government through
march 11th by prohibiting federal funds
from being distributed
to schools and child care centers to
have a covid19 vaccine mandate related
to enrollment
in-person attendance and participation
in school-related
activities
cruz is saying i'm going to throw a
gigantic wrench into the funding of this
government i'm willing to go all the way
on the line here to get this out how bad
do you want it democrats how bad do you
want to stand up and say no we no
parents we're willing to risk shutting
down the government
because we so badly want to inject your
little kids with this experimental drug
to maybe sort of possibly probably not
protect against a virus that poses
virtually no threat to them
how bad do you want it dems the
democrats know this is not popular at
all the democrats know that we've
actually got the will of the people on
our side here
and the democrats know we're in a
midterm election year this is really
smart politics from cruz in terms of
senators he he is the one who gets it
the most basically i don't just say that
because we do a show together verdict we
do a pot but part of the reason we do
the show together is because i've
recognized this guy gets it he's right
here on the senate and the guy who gets
it most in the governor's mansions is
ron desantis he's doing the same thing
ron desantis is going and he realizes
this is a big issue for parents and he's
saying we're not going to we're going to
use the power of the state to stop this
crap not only cruz and desantis who are
both definitely much more on the right
wing side of the republican party even
the most establishment republicans i'm
talking about cocaine mitch mcconnell
himself as establishment as they get
mitch mcconnell is leaning into
especially the school issue not just on
the vaccine mandates but on critical
race theory on the transgender stuff he
realizes
that this election the best the best
option for republicans the best
opportunity for republicans
in 2022
is to appeal to parents and the way he's
doing it is not just specifically going
after
critical race theory not just
specifically going after transgender
propaganda he's going after
curriculum
transparency
the far left is admitting
in public
that if the public gets to look at the
racial and gender theories that they
want to teach little kids
then those lesson plans will become
untenable
i'm going to say that again the far left
is admitting in public
that if the public gets to look at the
racial and gender theories that they
want to teach little kids
then these lesson plans will become
untenable
that's what they're actually
saying if parents gain transparency into
the crazy stuff we're teaching
we might
might have to stop teaching it
in other words their reaction proves the
point
the fact that woke bureaucrats are this
terrified by transparency proves exactly
exactly why parents deserve it
absolutely brilliant this is the way to
do it all we're saying because we live
in a culture now that loves openness and
transparency
and that they value these things above
above most other virtues
okay let's use it against the libs okay
because now the libs are on the side
against transparency and conservatives
are on the side for transparency and the
libs don't want transparency because
they know that the minute parents see
what their kids are actually being
taught in these schools they're going to
lose their minds rightly so because
they're saying i don't want my kid
having his head filled with this
ideological poison do you know how
potent this political issue is
just yesterday we saw three san
francisco school board members ousted
for being too far to the left over these
issues san francisco
san francisco about as live as they get
by a 70 percent vote
these far progressive leftist school
board members got ousted and the board
president i'm sorry the former board
president gabriella lopez what did she
blame it on white supremacy she says if
you fight for racial justice this is the
consequence don't be mistaken white
supremacists are enjoying this and the
support of the recall is aligned with
this
you know san francisco that city
famously teaming with white supremacists
san francisco 70
of the voters in san fran freaking cisco
are white supremacists
ku klux klan members that's the only
explanation for why they don't want
these sick weirdo perverts to try to
trans the kids that's the only
explanation right
except no there's not one
single white supremacist in san
francisco there's it's not
that's just white supremacy it put that
away with the easter bunny and the tooth
fairy it does not exist it is not real
it is the last desperate gasp of
democrats who recognize that the jig is
up that's what's going on and they're
going to try to use it in 2022 but if
this school board election in
san francisco is any indication
conservatives parents ordinary people of
all stripes are in very good shape
now
this
uh this this issue of
the
racial white supremacy
black supremacy i don't know whatever
this issue is ginning up okay there's no
ku klux klansman there are no white
supremacists running running mayhem all
over the country that's not the case as
lebron james says
that
the
every time a black man leaves his home
he's being hunted down i think lebron is
doing just fine okay
you are seeing a rise though in
identitarian politics and you're seeing
it not just from some kooks
on a blog or yelling in the streets
you're saying this from elected
democrats
eric adams eric adams the mayor of new
york
has just come out
and threatened
to stop taking questions from white
reporters
i'm a black man that's the mayor
but my story has been interpreted by
people that don't look like me
we got to be honest about that
how many blacks are in editorial
boards how many blacks have determined
how these stories are being written
how many asians
how many east indians how many south
asians
everybody talks about my government
being
what's
diversified
diversity diversification in the
newsrooms diversify
your newsroom so i can look out and see
people that look like me and if this is
how this is going to be
then i'm just going to come and do my
announcements and bounce
i'm not going to why am i even answering
these questions
and it happens over and over and over
again
it happens over and over and over again
you people keep asking me tough
questions and so i'm gonna stop taking
them and i'm gonna blame it on racism
because i got nothing because i got
nothing
and because of your terrible racism i'm
not i'm going to totally stop taking any
questions from whitey
uh
hold on who's doing who's doing the
racism mayor adams which one by the way
eric adams when he ran for mayor
one of the clips that went viral from
his campaign is that he was openly
bragging about how he loved to beat out
whitey how he loved to beat out those
crackers in the police department
every day in the police department i
kicked those crackers ass man i was
unbelievable in the police department
with one of the black toronto
enforcement
came the sergeant a lieutenant and the
captain
you know the story some people all of a
sudden trying to reinvent me but the
reality is what i was then is who i am
now
okay so eric adams doesn't have a whole
lot of credibility here to be talking
about
racism or whatever but it's always what
they do and and and the the democrats do
it because they've got nothing else and
so they're willing to do it even in the
most extreme circumstances even in san
francisco there was a woman called into
to david webb's show once his radio show
she called in and david webb is a
conservative and she was a liberal and
she was arguing with him and eventually
she completely lost the argument she
said well you're only saying that
because of your white privilege
now if you know david webb you know that
whatever
virtues he possesses white privilege is
not one of them david webb very much a
black man but she didn't know that it
was a radio show and so he starts
laughing he says lady i know you're
you're pulling the card that you guys
always pull but it's not going to work
on me
because you you didn't even do your most
basic level of homework to know who it
is that you're talking to and so that's
what eric adams is doing because eric
adams is a is just a dummy and an
incompetent and he can't govern new york
apparently any better than the bolshevik
that he replaced and there were people
who said look eric adams he was a cop
he's like a little bit more normal than
than bill de blasio maybe things will
get better it's not getting better at
all
and he's he's actually so incompetent
that he can't even answer basic
questions from mostly sympathetic
reporters and so he's saying all right
i'm going to stop answering questions
from from you entirely i'm going to come
in give my announcements and go and run
away
and i'm going to i'm going to
make jokes about the crackers and the
white reporters not exactly martin
luther king kind of stuff right
and and
not exactly persuasive either the reason
that the civil rights movement of the
1960s was very persuasive to a lot of
people and remains very persuasive at
least in theory to a lot of people is
because it co-opted patriotic language
the reason it worked is because martin
luther king didn't come out and say man
this country is terrible it's horrible
to black people the founding fathers are
big jerks i hate it we're going to have
a new country now i hate america's awful
he didn't do that he did exactly the
opposite he said america's got to live
up to her ideals america's got to live
up to her creed
jefferson and washington and adams they
would have loved me and they would have
loved my political supporters and you've
all got to get on board too and it's
extremely extremely
persuasive and then
basically before martin luther king's
body was cold they got rid of all of
that on the left and they they embraced
a much more aggressive anti-american
form of of activism and and it doesn't
really work i mean it's turning off a
lot of people and this is why the
democrats look like they're about to get
blown out in 2022. the only people that
that kind of aggressive anti-american
language convinces
are
well some radicals of all stripes and
colors but especially
white liberals
white liberals
are they're the they're the only groups
susceptible to white guilt they're the
only group that hears this kind of stuff
and says you're right you shouldn't
mayor adams you're right you shouldn't
take any any questions from us crackers
we're tara we're awful we're the worst
people in the world oh you're right in
san francisco it was just david duke and
bull connor that kicked you guys off the
school board it had nothing to do with
your
absolute failure and your your
radicalism of trying to indoctrinate
these kids no no it's because of
i don't know i guess strom thurmond must
have moved to san francisco no not at
all so so there was a an article just
came in the allied times
from brian cranston
bryan cranston was was just being
interviewed and cranston
has now
turned down
a part in a play because he felt the
part was was
too much partaking of his white
privilege he said i'm 65 years old
and i need to learn
i need to change
brian cranston needs to overcome
his white
privilege and this is really pathetic
well he does rank ransom has a lot of
privilege because he's one of the most
famous wealthy well-known performers in
the entire world
but this this kind of stuff is is really
pathetic i don't think it persuades
anyone i don't think it persuades black
people i don't think it persuades white
people i don't think it persuades any of
the other races of people i think it
persuades a very small percentage of
radicals
and and brian cranston actually went on
to make this interesting point
the new play
that he's doing is about the limits of
free speech he's saying look there's no
such thing as free speech absolutism
there's no such thing as having no
limits or taboos in in speech and in
standards and in society that's actually
the same point as my book he's brian
cranston is basically doing a play right
now about my book but the standards that
he wants are completely insane they're
leftist leftist standards
okay the
yes it's true the truckers and the blm
people who shut down the highways
they're doing kind of the same act
but the substance of that act is very
different
my friend andrew clavin points this out
consensual sex between a loving husband
and a wife and rape
can look
kind of like the same physical act but
they're completely different acts
because the substance is different
because the spiritual component is
different because the t loss of it is
different okay and that's what that's
what we're going to need to dig into we
need to dig into to what those
boundaries should be and what we want
our society for and if you're the one
killing the puppies you're probably the
bad guy i mentioned
our wonderful new film shut in earlier
but the daily wire is creating even more
incredible content for you movies comedy
documentaries and so much more it's not
just quality movies like shut in run
hide fight and the soon to be released
movie the hyperions
our summer blockbuster terror on the
prairie with gina carano that's coming
out too but when you become a member you
also get hard-hitting documentaries like
china the enemy within which is debuting
today the enemy within is a gripping
five-part series that shows how fauchy
biden the nba hollywood even our schools
have become beholden to china from the
acclaimed journalist and writer of the
plot against the president lee smith
when you sign up you also get access to
our one-of-a-kind shows like third
thursday book club candace debunked and
the search help us build a world of news
and entertainment that reflects your
values become a daily wire member today
go to dailywire.com watch to get caught
up on all of this new exciting content
dailywire.com
watch we'll be right back with a lot
more
welcome back to the show my favorite
part of the week when we get to hear
from you in the mailbag first question
up from gabe hey michael me and my
current girlfriend have been on and off
for the past two years we have a child a
beautiful baby girl she got pregnant
within a month of us knowing each other
she has struggled with substance abuse
specifically alcohol having to go to
rehab for it because of two duis in
about a a month's time
recently our relationship has been
getting strained again due to drinking
habits i'm adamant about trying to keep
our family together and raise our
daughter under the same roof i've been
vocal about not wanting her to drink
around me because of my request she
has asked that i stopped drinking as
well and agree not to do it around her
but she has
not stopped drinking
she won't do it even if it's just a beer
or two physical abuses in the past have
made me nervous whenever she drinks any
type of alcohol she says i'm trying to
control her as a defense i'm just
struggling between wanting to keep my
family together and this constant fight
about what is more important
i'm sorry to hear about your problem
but your impulse is right to keep your
family together when your wife says
you're trying to control her
she's right
you i hope she's right you should be
trying to control her
you are the head of your household
first of all you're the head of your hat
you should be the head of your household
i guess you're not you're not you're not
the head of your household in the sense
that it's you and your girlfriend
so actually let me temper what i just
said
if she were your wife you would be the
head of your household but she's not
your wife she's your girlfriend so one
you should get married
she has problems you have problems
everybody's got problems you should get
married you have a child together
get married
then you're the head of your household
you want to control your wife says
you're trying to control her yes she
should be controlled she's got a big
problem and you can help her with that
problem and it's your responsibility to
help her with that problem now one way
that she says you could help her is by
you stop drinking entirely but you don't
have an alcohol problem she does so why
should you stop drinking well because if
that's going to be the way to solve this
problem in your family then that's just
what you're going to have to do and
you're going to have to make that
sacrifice and she won't uphold her end
of the bargain well you're going to have
to try to find ways to make her uphold
her end of the bargain but you certainly
should uphold your end of the bargain
and it's not even just okay i'll stop
drinking
around you if if what is required is
that you just stop drinking well then
that's the way it goes pal
that's what that's what you're going to
have to do and that's going to give you
a lot more credibility when you say look
i am doing this it can be done and you
need to do it too and i'm ahead of this
family and you're asking me for help and
i'm willing to give the help but that's
the way that it's going to go
or should you just break up you should
not break up this is going to be a
slight digression but it's related and
it's real it is the issue
that is occupying my mind right now much
more than the russian invasion of
ukraine
okay
much more than
many other issues in the country
kim and kanye
the kim kanye skeet drama that's going
on right now is much more important to
the future of america than whatever
vladimir putin will or will not do in
ukraine
i mean that sincerely
because the kim kanye skeet drama is
about
family and the nature of marriage and
there have been huge attacks on family
and marriage in recent years i mean
they've redefined the whole thing from
this bench of the supreme court
or they've at least tried to but it
can't be redefined because it has a real
meaning okay
keep family together i got in a lot of
trouble on twitter yesterday because
i said i said hey i've got this crazy
idea
follow me if you will please hear me out
what if kim kardashian
reconciles with her contrite husband for
the sake of her children and and because
of the vows that she made before her
family and her community and her god
what if she did that that's what she
should do and the libs
screamed at me they were so angry
they said how dare you
kanye is an abuser first of all i don't
i don't i haven't heard any allegations
that kanye is like beating his wife or
anything i think that term is being used
as a complete excuse it's being defined
out of reality as a way to justify
divorce which the left has been after
for a long time but divorce is really
really bad okay and keeping a family
together is good
there are some cases i grant you there
are some cases if a woman is a punching
bag like a literal punching bag for
there are some cases in which a
separation
is uh not only prudent but probably
necessary morally necessary
but those are rare cases okay and if
it's if it's merely the case that you
and your wife don't get along or you and
your girlfriend in this case don't get
along that's not a good reason to
destroy a family that's really bad for
the kids it's really bad for a society
someone wrote to me they said well
michael marriage is a private thing it's
a private matter how you stop poking
your nose around in their marriage
whatever marriage is
it is not a private matter
marriage is very very much a public
matter that's why you invite all your
family to the wedding and that's why you
make vows in public
with a minister there before the
government and before the ultimate
government by the way before god that's
why you register with the civil
authority that's why you sign a contract
and then you have children marriage
involves lots and lots of other people
okay and for
the vast majority of the history of our
civilization
it was very very hard to get divorced
for goodness sakes the protestant
revolution happened because of a divorce
you had luther you had some things going
on in the continent but the protestant
revolution really took off because the
king of england wanted to divorce his
wife and the pope wouldn't let him
because he said you've got to keep your
marriage together you can't would
destroy the faith you're supposed to be
a defender of the faith and it would be
so scandalous and it was scandalous and
it destroyed england
that
sort of thing is very
very important the family is the
ultimate building
sorry the basic building block of
society if you destroy that your society
falls apart
which is why kim should take her
contrite husband back and stop screwing
around with skeet and it's why you
should marry your girlfriend first of
all and then you should
do your best as a loving husband to help
your wife through this process
long answer to a very good question but
it's an important question from drew
dear michael
i know that you're a fan of
conservatives in power actually using
their power for conservative purposes i
agree with you that the role of
governing authorities is to actually
govern many conservatives are split in
regard to hungarian prime minister
victor orban conservatives like
rodriguez see his pro-family and
anti-lgbt education policies as a model
for conservatives in the u.s and other
conservatives say he has authoritarian
tendencies and is illiberal
yeah okay well you know i'm a
conservative so the first thing i go for
is is not to protect the liberals right
that doesn't make a lot of sense i know
some people do but that's not what i do
what are your thoughts on urban and
should american conservatives support
him i suppose i've already given my
answer or bond is doing a good job he's
a politician all politicians have lots
of problems but urbana is doing a really
good job i'll show you an example
almost a unique example of how orban is
doing a good job
certainly unique in europe
europe has a dying population and
america has a dying population
this is i mean i mean that very
literally that there are fewer and fewer
people being born we're not replacing
ourselves the most basic
requirement of a civilization we're not
fulfilling that and haven't been for
decades
or bond turned it around
or bond turned around the declining
birth rates in hungary
or bond answered a lot of the
immigration problems that are bedeviling
the rest of the west or bonn turned that
around
so people are trying to call him a
fascist or so it's just completely
ridiculous he's doing a good job
generally speaking and yeah we should
learn from him from josh hey michael you
and others have mentioned previously
that trump running in 2024 is a problem
for desantis as he controls much of the
republican base i know the future is
uncertain but would it not be better for
desantis to bow out of the 2024
presidential race throw his support
behind donald trump keep crushing it as
governor for another four years and then
just run for president later likely with
the support of trump in his base i know
you usually get cultural and
relationship questions but i had this
political question and i didn't want to
ask ben thanks for everything you do
josh
i think that question is better directed
to president christie
you know president chris christie who
was he was doing a really good job as
governor of new jersey
in 2012 and a lot of people were calling
him to tell him this is it you should
run for president he said no you know
i'm going to wait it out and then i'll
let mitt have this one and then i'm
going to run next time and then i'm
going to get everybody's support it's
going to be great and what happened he
totally flopped
you don't win by losing this was the
problem with the never trump argument in
2016.
he said no here's what's going to happen
here this is that we're we've got this
planned out trump he's going to lose we
shouldn't vote for trump trump's really
bad he's going to lose hillary's going
to win and then you see this is the
genius hillary is going to be bad and so
she people are not going to like her and
then they're going to be really angry
and we're going to win the next time
that's not how politics works
that's you win by winning you don't win
by losing as mitch mcconnell says the
winners write laws and the losers go
home
politics also comes in cycles time
matters with politics desantis right now
is i think as hot as he's ever going to
be
the way he talks the way he looks the
way he governs the covid crisis his
impulses they're they're right on the
money right now
there is no reason to believe that they
will be right on the money four years
from now
and even politicians who don't win the
first time who for president who
almost no one wins the first time other
than donald trump donald trump is the
one guy who the first time he runs for
office becomes the president of the
united states but otherwise it doesn't
happen
even the people who then run and they
run and they run and then eventually
they win i'm thinking of ronald reagan
right ronald reagan made moves to run in
68 then he runs in 76 then he finally
wins in 80.
he's in it he's in the fight he's not
just saying hey gerald ford you have it
this time and then hey you guys have it
this hey richard nixon that's cool
whatever then i'm gonna get it later no
he was always in the he was at least
making moves to run
and then he does run against joel ford
and then he and then he wins in 1980. i
think if desantis wants to be president
i think he's got to run from john hey
michael i know you are no avid sports
fan however i've noticed a natural
explosion in conservative values and
stars in the ufc what are your thoughts
on a gladiator sport like mixed martial
arts
why do you feel like the sport has
become the most conservative when it
comes to values and do you watch and
have a favorite fighter
i don't watch but i do like it i do like
it because i like boxing boxing has also
always been a pretty conservative sport
a friend of mine a friend of mine from a
cigar bar in new york of many years was
a heavyweight boxer a pretty well-known
heavyweight boxer and
i we had been friends for a while before
i realized he was a republican and he
said oh yeah man boxers they're almost
all republicans i don't know just it's
kind of a conservative sport you see it
a little bit with baseball baseball it's
a pretty right-wing sport
you don't see it with
basketball you don't see it certainly
you don't see it with football so
different sports are are
the politics varies why is that well uh
boxing is a beautiful sport right it's
this beauty uses your whole body it's
very artful we think of it as just
bludgeoning people to death but there's
actually a great deal of beauty to it a
great deal of finesse a great deal of
strategy and i guess mixed martial arts
turns that up to 11. it's more violent i
guess in that way
but i think that might have something to
do with it
it's also what was that line from
from
iron man
the robert downey jr who had all those
problems in the 90s and 2000s he went to
jail and when he was asked how he became
politically sort of conservative he said
it's very hard to uh to you know go into
jail to go into these very aggressive
violent environments and come out a
liberal what's the line from mike tyson
everybody's got a plan until he gets
punched in the face i think that i think
that
ballast of reality is probably why
why you see that as well from verrinder
dear michael
you say you do very little exercise you
enjoy culinary delights how do you keep
yourself in good shape
good genes my friend that's how now the
actual way because i
very rarely exercise
the only thing that even gets me to
consider exercising is my echelon
bicycle because it's in my house so i
can't it's not like i'm going to go to
the gym or something like that
the actual thing that keeps me in shape
is moderation because while i love my
good italian pastas and my hoagies and
all this stuff i do try to
keep it in moderation okay i do try to
not have the seventh bowl of pasta all
right i do try to i try to make sure
look the camera adds 10 pounds all right
i got i got to keep it svelte all right
i got to keep doing maybe i'll do a
little exercise every now and again but
moderation is a virtue people think that
we conservatives are to the right of
genghis khan and therefore we're not
moderate but actually that we're
moderate as well i don't think that the
libs and the squishes and the centrists
i don't think they have a great sense of
moderation from jonathan last question
michael over the past several months
i've gotten romantically involved with a
fellow co-worker we share the same
values and enjoy each other's company
everything's great aside from two
caveats she's 10 years older than me and
has been married once i'm 24. she does
not have children i like her but i
wonder if i should
be concerned about the age difference or
the fact that she's been married once
before so far it's not been an issue
thank you for your time
it depends what you want my friend
you know you'd have to especially if
you're catholic you'd have to figure out
the nature of that was that first
marriage a legitimate marriage elicit
marriage or was it not if it was then
you can't get married if it wasn't then
you know i guess you could but it also
depends on what you want if you want to
have a lot of kids then that's probably
not going to work i've seen it work i
have friends who who are married to
women who are
10 years older than them and it works
out fine and it's a wonderful
arrangement
but but
this there's not going to be a hard and
fast rule here you do have to ask for
yourself
what
is it that you want how do you see
marriage frankly it gets a little bit to
the kim and kanye question it gets to a
big broad political question too which
is what are we all doing here together
i'm sorry that i'm not giving you a
direct answer on date this woman or
don't date this woman i don't know the
details so i can't i can't really give
you a hard and fast answer but what i do
know
is that
we need to answer those questions if
we're going to move forward in our big
broad political culture in our local
communities and in that basic political
institution the family we're lost in a
sea of relativism right now nobody has
any idea what the hell we're doing or
what any of it's for so it's just a
brute battle of power and interest and
what we're going to need to do is apply
a little bit of logic to that and get
back to some sense of what is it that we
want and that's how we're going to get
back to society open up the restaurants
go back to school stop transiting the
kids and stop killing the puppies i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you monday
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode don't forget
to subscribe and if you want to help
spread the word please give us a five
star review and tell your friends to
subscribe we're available on apple
podcasts spotify and wherever else you
listen to podcasts
also be sure to check out the other
daily wire podcasts including the ben
shapiro show the andrew clavin show and
the matte wall show the michael knowles
show is produced by ben davies executive
producer jeremy boring our technical
director is austin stevens supervising
producer mathis glover production
manager pavel vadovsky editor and
associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin